Rồi tên Rồi Tên, có quan năng lộng quốc tệ ER ngày 2018 đã cương bối cái đệ xuất.
Nhanh giảm ám lực giá năng lộng đối với người thương dùng.
Trong bối cảnh giá râu tăng cao giúp đột giống Mỹ, SRL và Yvang,
các quên nghị tập trung vật việc các sản như cầu tư thủ như liệu ở cơm độ chính phổ.
Sơn nhẹp vào hợp xa đình.
ER cho rằng việc làm việc tương xà, hạnh phíaomi chuyển không cần thiết.
Bà giảm tức độ phương tiện chỉ đồng có tóc.
Có thể có phần giảm tức thủ đồng lợp.
Tức quan này cũng gynh hệ hệm chỉ sử dụng đường hành thông.
khi có các phương thương bạn tải thay thay thay phua hợp.
Chuy đó, EA đã thông nhất trên khai đật sạch khó dấu khẩn cấp lần nhất từ truyền này
với khoảng bón trông trở thủng dòng từ các khó dự trữ chính lợp nhá mồn định thị trường.
Mỹ là Cui Sao có đam góp phần lần trụ lợp xả khó này.
Giám đấu điều anh EA cho biết,
các bạn thóc nói trên là những dải phát khủng thể của thị trình khai ngày.
Nhâm dạm các đậu từ giá nó lợp tăng cao.
Tôi nhé anh thiệu quả anh của các bạn thích thân này,
sự thuận và mướng độ của hợp và thực hiện của các khu dài.